Fearless Relentless and one of the most
utterly brutal Warriors to ever walk the
face of the Earth with a body count
somewhere in the high hundred thousands
if not well into multiple Millions given
just how long he's been around for many
of you will already be well aware of
scp-076-2 also known as able on the
surface he's a man of Middle Eastern
descent covered in tattoos of occult
symbols and demonic faces usually
contained within a stone Cube designated
as
scp-076-1 Abel will often emerge in a
homicidal State killing anyone and
anything directly around him how well by
any means available to him but primarily
by pulling a wide array of bladed
weapons seemingly out of thin air this
is thanks to a tiny pocket Dimension
that only he can reach into which is
also always stocked with an assortment
of deadly implements for his latest
murder spray as of being highly combat
proficient and always armed didn't make
him enough of an imposing threat
scp-076-2 also possesses a near
superhuman resistance to damage making
him incredibly difficult to take down
and even if someone is able to
eventually neutralize him able will also
come back resurrecting inside
scp-076-1 to fight another day what you
may not know is for a Time Abel actually
worked alongside the SCP Foundation
although nowadays they prefer to keep
him locked away in a secure containment
facility underwater which they will
flood with seawater if he ever escapes
but Abel was once appointed the leader
of his own mobile task force
omega-7 referred to under the code name
of Pandora's Box you see the foundation
realized that
scp-076-2 held an especially high regard
for those who proved well able to best
him in combat and it was this range code
of honor that Abel held that the
foundation hoped to exploit with the
creation of Pandora's Box comprised of
MTF operatives that had earned Abel's
respect most by previously beating him
in a fair fight or as Fair as a fight
with a man who can summon swords through
a tear in the fabric of reality can be
these agents would support Abel during
missions in the field during which the
SCP Foundation were able to deploy the
anomalous warrior in various tactical
engagements however this didn't last
long eventually Abel grew tired of
carrying out the orders of the
foundation The Immortal Warrior craved a
challenge Breaking Free of containment
and turning on the foundation resulting
in able being neutralized by an on-site
nuclear weapon this marked the end of
the fragile alliance between
scp-076-2 and the SCP Foundation leaving
the existence of omega-7 a classified
secret and one of the organization's
most embarrassing missteps well but what
if that hadn't happened what I felt
there in the infinite Multiverse there
was a world where Abel had been allowed
to remain a part of omega-7 and the
mobile task force was never disbanded
well you're about to find out in our
world Abel's dissatisfaction with being
a member of Pandora's Box first became
apparent when he began putting the rest
of his unit through live fire exercises
brutalizing his men despite these
exercises being intended as for training
purposes only but in this world the
injuries and even casualties Abel
inflicted on the rest of omega-7 were
met with a much different response the
o5 Council of this alternate version of
the SCP Foundation viewed Abel's
outbursts during training as acceptable
losses every time he would injure one of
omega-7 the council would demand that
Replacements be on hand to become part
of the task force drawn from the ranks
of the other mtfs at their disposal
after all Abel was a valuable asset for
carrying out the foundation's Dirty Work
by continually replenishing his team
with reserves from their seemingly
inexhaustible supply of other MTF agents
the o5 Council of this world were able
to keep
scp-076-2 firmly under their employee
however it is also important to note
that Abel's patience for these new
recruits was far more limited than the
original omega-7s those men had all been
hand-picked by Abel personally and
appointed to the project given that he
had some modicum of respect for them as
combatants whereas all of their
Replacements were plucked at random from
the foundation's other mtfs as a result
scp-076-2 would carelessly kill or wound
more and more of these reserves during
combat missions hardly distinguishing
between friend and foe but despite this
the o5 council refused to discontinue
the omega-7 project viewing these as
acceptable losses and letting the
success rate of Abel's missions justify
the depletion of their other mobile task
forces under Abel's leadership and the
command of the o5 council omega-7 would
become the foundation's primary rapid
response unit and the most deployed task
force for Dangerous field operations and
working for the foundation meant that
every field mission was a highly
dangerous one such was the case during
one Containment Breach where scp-682
managed to get free of its acid tank a
rampaging infinitely adaptable hard to
destroy reptile on the loose
slaughtering all in its path was bad
enough but the o5 council had received
Intel that there was something more
behind this breakout than it first
seemed and so Abel and the rest of his
latest omega-7 team were sent in to
pacify
scp-682 bursting into the facility eager
to once again be freed from containment
and the monotonous underwhelming
experience of training able flew into
combat drawing black swords from his
personal Armory he began to tear through
everything and everyone in his path
unfortunately for the foundation
Personnel on site this also meant that
they were subject to Abel's Relentless
wrath as if running away from scp-682
wasn't that enough fleeing research
staff were quickly met with the swing of
scp-076-2's weapons and removed from the
premises in a brutal fashion still this
meant little to Abel and even less to
the o5 council as far as they were
concerned even their own staff were just
collateral damage more acceptable losses
justified by Abel's perfect record for
successful high-risk High reward field
missions however that perfect record was
about to be tarnished for good you see
this Containment Breach wasn't your
average
scp-682 escape attempt it was instead a
situation that had been meticulously
planned and carried out for one purpose
this breach was intended specifically to
draw Abel out since he had become the
SCP foundation's primary weapon response
to danger in the field a particularly
devious third party had begun to take
note the chaos Insurgency a splinter
faction that began its life as an off
the books Black Ops unit for the
foundation themselves had been
monitoring Abel's deployment by the o5
council in this universe their origin
was the same as an ours and the
Insurgency took a certain disdain to
seeing an anomalous individual carrying
out the kind of operations their group
had been formed to undertake for the
foundation additionally the use of
scp-076-2 as a personal attack dog by
the o5 council is hypocrisy the
Insurgency believed in the practical
application of anomalies rather than
mocking them up and keeping them
contained and it was for this belief
that they had been vilified by the
foundation and yet here was the same
organization sending Abel on missions
with no care for the harm he caused and
so as a result the chaos Insurgency had
conducted an operation to break into the
foundation free scp-682 and send the
hard to destroy reptile on a rampage
also they could take their shot at able
being ambushed by a group of cows
Insurgency operatives on his way to
engage
scp-682 Abel was admittedly caught by
surprise but by now his combat prowess
was second to almost nobody else in the
world the insurgents dog piled on April
unleashing every ounce of Firepower they
had brought to bear on the immortal
Warrior the ensuing firefight destroyed
an entire wing of the foundation
facilities explosive weapons being
detonated in the hopes that the
Insurgency could subdue Abel all the
while
scp-076-2 Shrugged off the oncoming
damage catching rockets that were
launched at him and throwing them back
in the direction of the chaos insurgents
it was a bloodbath nearly the entire
Omega 17 that had accompanied Abel and
provided him with fire support were
lying dead the same could also be said
for the insurgency's forces too though
with each of them being gradually felled
by the Warrior's many weapons but by
this point Abel was approaching
exhaustion and there was still one more
enemy left standing it had been
unfurling destruction all on its own
angrily devouring the few Foundation
Personnel that were left and now the
scaly form of scp-682 came lumbering
around the corner the battle was brutal
in this universe Abel and the hard to
destroy reptile had never crossed paths
before but scp-682 could smell the
difference in Abel's physiology his
innate ability to resist damage and
resurrect time and time again the
creature already held the stain for
anything and everything living and so
presented with a man who technically
couldn't stop living
scp-682 entered an Unstoppable rage
State taking the exhausted able down
with ease but losing in a grudge match
against
scp-682 wasn't quite as bad as things
were about to get for Abel Reviving
inside of his Stone sarcophagus the
ancient warrior was confused the
foundation weren't letting him out it
had been a long time years even since he
had last died even temporarily over the
course of all of his omega-7 missions he
hadn't needed to reappear back inside
scp-076-1 for quite a considerable while
and now that he had a very large seed of
Doubt had been sown the o5 council were
Furious just as angry at
scp-076-2's apparent failure as Abel was
the perfect operational track record of
their top anomalous asset was now
tarnished the question started to spread
through the council members if their
sword Wheeling virtually invulnerable
secret weapon wasn't as effective as
they had previously thought then what
was the use of continuing to deploy Abel
and so began a debate within the o5
council upon what was to be the fate of
scp-076-2 in this University had served
the foundation well but a weapon that is
only effective even ninety percent of
the time still leaves a margin of error
it was that risk that potential for
error knowing that Abel wouldn't always
succeed in his missions that caused the
o5 council to reconsider his
applications as a field operative there
were some in the council who argued that
this was a highly specific isolated
incident the chaos Insurgency had
specifically engineered the scp-682
Escape as a way to draw Abel out after
all just because he failed this time did
not indicate a pattern of failure but
this argument was eventually shot down
especially when the foundation's Ethics
Committee decided to throw in their two
cents they demanded able status as a
field agent be revoked and levied for
the immediate disbanding for the omega-7
project pulling replacements for that
task force from other mtfs at the
foundation had left them with a
significantly depleted reserve of troops
and then came the argument about just
how acceptable the losses were when able
was let loose a decision was ultimately
made to for at least the moment rescind
scp-076-2's field operative privileges
and suspend any further development of
or recruitment into omega-7 however
there was one crucial factor that nobody
on the council had taken into
consideration when they made their
verdict and that was how badly Abel
would react to the news as you may have
already predicted Abel was Furious to
hear he would be held in containment
until further notice his anger stemmed
not from his defeat at the jaws of
scp-682 but at how quick the foundation
seemingly was to question his combat
prowess he lost one battle out of
hundreds thousands even and all of a
sudden the o5 council were going to lock
him away all because of one defeat you
dare Abel bellowed when he was given the
news I Am The Greatest Warrior on this
planet and have been made a pond by your
foundation I give you my strength my
skill and the moment I falter you'll
turn your back on me you damn you dare I
will show you what real power looks like
overcome with rage it didn't take long
for Abel to force his way out of
containment he'd been active as a field
agent within the foundation for so long
now that he had long since figured out a
way to escape his underwater prison
before the emergency containment
measures had a chance to stop him as he
broke free he made sure to take down
plenty of security staff along along the
way and to make matters worse he didn't
stop there before long Abel was on a
Warpath against the SCP Foundation every
few days reports would come in of a
massacre at a foundation facility
security footage recovered from the
wreckage after each incident would show
Abel arriving Prime for battle a sword
in each Hand by the time he left after
his brutal remorseless attack he'd be
drenched in the blood of the entire
site's Personnel the foundation had
little in its once huge Arsenal to fight
back with given the number of MTF agents
reassigned to omega-7 their forces were
far more limited if not almost depleted
they dispatched attachments to clean up
the wake of Abel's destruction but not
one Squad sent after the anomalous
Warrior came back alive part of the
problem was the foundation couldn't
predict where Abel would show up next or
which of their sights he knew about and
was planning to hit from their
perspective his attacks were spontaneous
the result of Rage at the foundation but
without any premeditated plan in mind
and that was exactly what Abel wanted
them to think by seeming to attack at
random he was therefore able to cover
the true intention behind each
engagement he was looking for something
during his considerable time leading
omega-7 he had heard about a machine
that could improve anything placed
inside of it
scp-914 better known as the Clockworks
and before long Abel found what he was
looking for by the time the foundation
realized what the Unstoppable Warrior's
plan was it was already too late Abel
was storming into the facility that
housed scp-914 with no intention of
leaving until he'd used it the
foundation had banned testing of
biological matter within the Clockworks
but Abel wasn't beholden to their rules
anymore in fact he barely was when he'd
worked with them before cutting down
guards and researchers survivors fleeing
in Terror Abel stepped up towards the
massive gears and cogs the Clockwork
components that made up scp-914 he
wasted no time setting the machine to
very fine with this setting the
Clockworks would take whatever was in
the input booth and improve it usually
by giving it anomalous Properties or in
the case of Able by giving him further
anomalous properties stepping inside the
were of Machinery drowned out the
emergency alarms as Abel reached his
goal to become the ultimate warrior the
embodiment of the very concept itself
racing to the scene a chopper cleared
the smoke as it approached under an
emergency executive order from the o5
council The View surviving remnants of
the foundation's mobile task forces had
been combined into a singular Strike
Team there were not many left
considering how many others from their
units had been previously siphoned into
omega-7 only to die as collateral damage
in the team's missions with Abel
remember SCP 070
7 sifield Commander burnt while the MTF
Strike Team held their guns nervously
aboard the aircraft primary objective is
to neutralize him by any means reports
indicate that he may be trying to access
scp-914 so be advised An Almighty
explosion boomed through the Airborne
vehicle engulfing the cockpit in Flames
beta
beta the commander radioed to Foundation
command everyone brace yourselves for
impact the helicopters spiraled out of
the air crashing to the ground in a
Twisted hunk of metal the surviving
members of the Strike Team scrambled out
of the wreckage hauling the more badly
wounded out of the ruined aircraft
contact someone yelled in horror enemy
contact behind us the remaining
Foundation foot soldiers turned and Drew
their weapons opening fire on something
suspended a few feet in the air above
them a hail of gunfire rang out as the
team opened fire the second they saw who
it was it was able and he was flying
floating above them his hair whipped in
the wind the oncoming storm of bullets
seemed to Ricochet off his skin in
actuality they weren't even hitting him
melting away before they could make
contact they might as well have been
firing pea shooters for how little
effect their guns had the barrage only
stopped when one of the Strike Team
launched a short-range rocket at the
newly refined Warrior it detonated but
when the smoke from the blast cleared
Abel was still hovering in the air
without so much as a scratch my turn he
announced reaching into his pocket
Dimension Abel pulled something out not
a weapon not yet instead it was a
formless dark shadowy mass that moved
like liquid metal reacting to the
movement of his hand as he drew the
substance out it formed seemingly at
Abel's command and it wasn't just swords
he could create now drawing on his
experiences from his omega-7 missions
any weapon that Abel had previously seen
or could think of he now had at his
disposal the Strike Team looked up in
horror as a veritable swarm of black
non-reflective constructs hovered in the
air on either side of Abel each one in
the shape of a rocket flinging both arms
towards the foundation troops Abel sent
his New Creations raining down on them
the Strike Team turned heal and fled for
their lives although none of them got
very far Abel's Rockets engulfed the
area around them in a volley of
explosions leaving not a single thing
standing he had just effortlessly built
an airstrike from virtually thin air and
thrown it at the foundation's last
remaining MTF agents and he wasn't done
there with his Newfound Powers Abel's
Campaign Of Destruction swept the entire
world in a last Act of desperation the
SCP Foundation offered freedom to any
anomaly that permanently took down
scp-076-2 they all flooded out of
containment to take their shot the
plague doctor the shy guy the Specter
but they barely slowed Abel down his new
constructs were devastating weapons
taking the form of not just blades but
projectiles of every size and shape all
of them lethal before long Abel had Lane
waste to the entire Foundation but still
he wanted more
scp-914 hadn't just improved Abel's
existing anomalous powers and granted
him the ability to fly at supersonic
speeds in doing so it had Amplified his
range too he loathed the human race and
sought to absolutely decimate every
single living thing no one could best
him in combat now and in his mind
Twisted by anger not one of them was
worthy of his respect he tore planes
apart with his bare hands smashed tanks
to pieces and leveled entire cities with
his unlimited weapons it took a few
years maybe a decade at the most but by
the end of it Abel sat atop a pile of
billions upon billions of bones with his
refined abilities he had done something
Unthinkable committed omnicide he had
killed everyone in the world of course
this was indeed another world one
different to ours luckily here our
version of Abel is still locked up
underwater but somewhere out there there
is an Abel who is watching the sun
rising over an entirely dead World his
world want to own an SCP of your own go
to scpswag.com for premium anomalous
merchandise now to see the result of
more anomalous experiments with the
Clockworks go and check out what if
scp-0 496 was put inside scp-914 and
scp-914 what did you put in it for more
Clockworks related stories